I had no idea that you were the flash
all you done for everyone no this was
doodad and zoom I'm so sorry I promise
you I'm gonna take from him what do you
took from you erase barriers between you
and me see who's the fastest man alive
that can't be everything you watched
classic psychopath
why can't they ever just say what they
want to do this power amplifier can be
easily weaponized it was to take out
every other planet in the multiverse
that's why he wants to race he wants the
energy I create when I run don't listen
and wait for him to kill somebody else
no I want him to suffer for everything
that he's done you want revenge if
that's why you're doing this you will
lose
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash finale trailer video they
released some extra footage and it
sounds like they might be doing crisis
on Infinite Earths I'm gonna explain
what that means and what they might be
doing with it on the TV show because
it's not gonna be exactly like the comic
book so if you haven't read crisis on
Infinite Earths you didn't know how the
flash died during that you don't need to
read it because the plot of the TV show
is gonna be vastly different especially
going into season 3 now there are a
number of different directions they
could take it but if you've ever read a
flash storyline you know that the flash
can go it like he can die get absorbed
into the Speed Force and come back many
many times there have been several times
when many different versions of the
flash have disappeared into the Speed
Force never to be heard from again until
another crisis happens in they reappear
the big new storyline they're doing in
the comics this week it's actually
dropping this week is DC rebirth if
you've ever read the flash rebirth
imagine a rebirth across all of DC's
main titles so Batman rebirth Green
Lantern rebirth new flash rebirth I'm
not gonna talk too much about what's
going on during that because it's not
related to what the TV show is doing but
there are some interesting things
there's a new flash arc with a new
speedster villain called Godspeed that's
coming in the comics I don't think the
TV show is doing that but I'll reference
it just a little bit because there are
some things happening in this trailer
that sound a little bit like what's
going to be happening in that flash arc
just just with the creation of new
speedsters so everybody's always
wondering is Jesse quick and Wally
West's gonna get powers well if they're
talking about this giant speed amplifier
creating this crazy speed for storm then
that might be a backdoor for them to get
powers but if they're going to resurface
the real version of Jay Garrick which I
know we're all hoping that he's the man
in the iron mask this would also be a
backdoor to repowering him if zoom has
stolen his speed the moment that really
got me though in this trailer is
different from previous trailers is when
they actually talked about destroying
all of the worlds of like oh he's
talking about crisis that's amazing I
can't believe they're doing that this
soon so just to explain what happened
during that and what what might be
happening in this finale is the
anti-monitor was going around destroying
all the universes the heroes of the
multiverse had to team up to stop him
but his measure of last resort was this
giant gun that he was going to fire
across space to destroy Earth so what
Barry Allen did is he
ran around it so fast that he destroyed
it but in doing so ran faster than he
had ever run before turning himself into
pure energy making it seem like he had
died in what DC did what they used that
event for was to transition from the
Silver Age of comics to the modern age
Wally West became the new proper flash
he's like I'm wearing the mantle of the
flash now I'm gonna honor Barry's memory
by taking his costume taking his name
and trying to be the best flash that I
can be so that began the Wally West era
of flash comics but the TV show isn't
getting rid of Grant Gustin it's not
like they're gonna kill him off in Wally
West is gonna be the flash I think what
they're just teasing is is that Barry
will run so fast like they'll get so
powerful that he'll turn into pure
energy in between seasons what they
might do is just tease you with the idea
that he's stuck in the Speed Force and
doesn't know how to come back so they
might use this iris tether thing that
they talked about in the previous
episode Barry come back to me I feel
like that's gonna be a really important
story beep for the finale I can't
remember the dialogue exactly but it was
like you know no matter what Barry
you'll always come back to me come home
to me so we think that's gonna be a big
part of this because if they're gonna be
amplifying their power soon wants to
absorb all the Speed Force so he might
turn into pure energy that's probably
how they're gonna deal with him but
Barry's seeming death might be
collateral damage from that so that
between seasons he has to find a way to
get home but a lot of that will just
depend on what ends up happening in the
finale so we'll have to wait to see it
but I really like the idea that it
presents an opportunity for the rest of
team flash to rise up to up their game
so Wally West is like okay I understand
you're the flash now I can't believe all
the sacrifices you've made I feel
inspired to be a hero myself so this is
a big call to action for Wally big call
to action for Jesse quick all the other
people on Team flash so beyond that I
don't want to speculate too much about
how this might actually change the
multiverse because it would be really
cool if they found a way to merge Cara's
earth with earth one but most of this
season has been about earth one or two
stories so we'll just have to wait and
see what happens but there's been a
number of storylines in the comics where
they've merged different earths so we
could see people from Earth 2 coming to
earth one on a permanent basis but I
don't really know if they're gonna go in
that direction so I don't want to talk
about it too much but what about this
summer the really interesting thing
that's happening right now is that all
the writers on a lot of TV shows all
over
Hollywood are going back to work this
week this is like their first week of
work as they break the next season so we
might start hearing stuff about flash
season three
they usually cast people as they head
into the summer so the actors are gonna
be working again really soon comic-con
is still a ways off that's not happening
till the end of the summer so that's
usually when they drop new trailers but
I'm actually hoping they start doing
stuff before then but it should go
without saying of course I'm gonna be
doing flash videos all summer it'll just
depend on what you guys want to talk
about and what ends up happening in the
finale because then we'll have a much
better idea of where they're taking
things in season three and if you guys
want I will do some DC rebirth videos I
don't do a lot of pure comic book videos
because it's mostly like TV movie stuff
but I will mention new flash stuff a lot
of you guys have been asking me about
the new god speed villain in the comics
but I don't know if the TV show is gonna
do him so I've been waiting to see so a
quick reminder finale tomorrow there is
a new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I don't
know if I'm gonna do an arrow finale
trailer video but it seems like they're
gonna be doing mayor Oliver Queen next
year we also have x-men apocalypse
coming I'll be doing a couple videos for
that but Ninja Turtles is coming to I'll
do a video for that too Stephen Amell
has been doing press fort he actually
served pizza at a New York pizzeria just
for fun doesn't this make you wish that
they would do like a pop-up jitter stand
where like the cast of the flash serves
coffee for a couple days just to promote
season three I'm also gonna be doing
some war crap videos too there's
actually a cool warcraft giveaway that
they're doing they're giving away free
copies of the game for people that buy
movie tickets so we'll do a video
explaining that later so much awesome
stuff happening this week why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Game of Thrones video
from last night episode 5 video and you
can click here to learn all about
Justice Society happening on next season
of legends of tomorrow thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight